citizens of the reject Nation it is time today
to watch Wonder Woman Bloodlines which in the
continuity I follow means we get some Zoo
sculpting from clay definitely you learn
all about her Heritage coins family tree
it's a Ken Burns documentary also hit that
subscription Bell if you haven't already hit
that like button so I know that you like this
very video and leave in the comments which
origin you follow for Wonder Woman because
I'm always very curious and while you're there
commenting let us know which one of these you
want us to watch next as we dive deeper into
the dcautcamudc Universe DC e-u-d-c I don't
even know anymore leave a comment yelling
at me about labeling this very video wrong
I know today I am groovy koi I'm ready
to get bloody how are you sir I'm good
um I'm thinking of bloody this would allow you to
cover your blood it is a bad first shirt if you
got punched in the chest repeatedly and you're
all bloody and you want to hide it boom bad for
sure you know who gets punched in the chest a lot
Batman you two can hide that bruising and pretend
be a billionaire playboy philanthropist and do
it in style look very swaggerific yeah when you
visit our shopzeroedition.com store how else
you can be squaggerific you can head over to
the patreon to become a super sexy reject
and dive right into there to watch us watch
this in its entirety beginning to end front to
back and our resting faces head on over to the
patreon to become a super sexy reject now without
further Ado let's watch Wonder Woman bloodlines
[Music]
this is Captain Trevor at fortnite
we got modes of transportation we got boom
tubes we got we got Jets we gotta chase
I'll take it Lieutenant are you seeing what
I'm seeing copy that sir we've got incoming
black Adam's here
I'm so sad they shaved his James Cameron
goatee I know I just I don't connect who
is this man who is this Steve
Trevor but nightmares like that
that's why you shaved it's a
fire frankly it would have caught
wait didn't hear any team's timeline five
years ago five years ago yeah that's why
he hasn't grown yet he's younger that's right
that's what it is it's lack of goatee confused
me he still needs to visit the abyss
does he grow at four one woman little
you know it's PG-13 show like I'm gonna careful
first couple minutes of the video demonetized
it's crucial this looks like heaven and
you're an angel you're still lightheaded
from your injuries I'm Diana but I'll still
take the compliment oh [__] just calm down
great reaction you are safe here on the mascara
home to the Amazons ruled by my mother Queen
apolita saved by a princess is there a problem I
mean traditional gender roles don't tell Twitter
Steve's a real man it's all healed wow what is
this thing the purple healing Ray that's your hand
what is it called the purple healing ring some
kind of alien demons are invading the earth look
nobody knows about these creatures and I've got
to warn them you will be held in the cells of
Justice until my mother in the Senate can decide
your fate it's not Justice lady you're gonna put
me in jail I haven't done anything no no no
no no you can't I need to get back I have to
warn them this is the future the woke mob wants
jail him for being a man blonde white male traps
for being a blonde gravest crime of them all
oh who does he think he is his Land of Women
your next coin frankly can't keep it up I think my
mother has proven hospitality is not her priority
yeah princess what brings you here
unfortunately this breaking them out
Stephen Trevor of man's world I am here to take
you home but shouldn't we be headed that way
nope once we get to the boat I can take you
across the barrier and back to your people
Point me toward the boat and I can take it from
here I saw the demon that killed your friends
and destroyed your craft you need my help too
right my mother taught me that an Amazon does
what is right no matter the cost Diana I
didn't mean it like this not so literally
and not you I mean like generally a Amazonian
we'll pick one you will return that prisoner
to his cell you will thank me for my mercy
and we will never discuss this again pause
go wait in the car Stephen
I've sworn to return him to his people
and I intend to go with him if you wish
to steal from the Amazons you will have to go
through their protector it's what you taught me
[Music]
it's fun how they animate with them using like
Z figurations like the Snyder uh directing yeah
oh yeah spicy if you leave you will never
become Queen are you truly willing to throw
away everything you are for the mere chance of
helping them you put it like that oh [Music]
oh Double Down
it's me again mother this is great
so far it's strange that you should
be my own daughter and yet someone I do not
recognize anymore you raised her right yeah
Pride it's okay she'll come around before
she like dies tragically or something yeah
oh don't let her see you cry turn away
Robin Wright Penn Big Girls Don't Cry
Oh sorry Robin Wright 2021 when this was
made I believe that's right that's right
how do you how do you leave this for
Superman I mean I know he's Superman
but like this is adorable yeah five
years ago you already forgot about
James Cameron it's not fair man
Justice for Cameron it's not right
so long why don't I hear sweeping if I sweep
anymore my arms are gonna fall off he's an actual
literal princess is coming here if your arms fall
off it is a small price to pay oh my god did I
check the expiration date on the Potpourri
one day makes all the difference a princess
yes but you should call me
Vanessa I mean Diana right
young Daphne's confused too [Laughter] I
know Velma says drinking references there
um why don't I show you the rest of the house
I know how you feel I have a strong mother
too make her your Apprentice what will you
dedicate your life to I don't know
killing teenage vampires yes don't
worry vampires aren't real I wasn't worried
and they are in fact I got a guy you should
meet about that you're serious I want to be
something else anything else have you told
your mother told me what that I've suddenly
allowed people to put their shoes on the bed
I like that this is just like a family
drama yeah so there's no car chase yeah
and to establish tone there will be a scene
in a car with an argument oh I like that yes
oh dude she's crushing it letter crush it
look at that 4.0 doing the work [Music]
yep knew this was coming Pete
for a second I thought she was wearing an
X-Men logo but that is an anarchy symbol
she is getting deeper into it get that undercut
I had one of those back in the day oh yeah well
half cutter and undercut yeah just the one side
but yeah just show them die she's really excited
what's the new fit fresh drip um it's totally
embarrassing what's she gonna be a superhero you
can't even drive yet you're like a baby you and
she learns to drive are you trying trying not in
Gotham Diane is already taking missions Julia
I'm sure I could help many by joining you but
this is the right way to help for me then that's
what you should do what Dang thank you sisters oh
I'll make you proud whatever so what's your code
name blood lights yes great lady fantastic femme
oh yeah like the idea of all alliterations for
women like a great Mercury name yeah greatness
hampered your day exactly my grandma is
there a street Trevor goatee origin film
yeah when did he grow it the last
five years I need to know Julia
it's been too long oh where's the kiddo
though summer Tidings it's Vanessa
I'm trouble I found some disturbing emails in
her office if Dr kale read these Veronica kale
the pharmaceutical magnet what does a drug
company want with archaeologists our work at
kale Pharmaceuticals is valuable but I fear that
it hasn't been profitable enough for my daughter
oh boy finesse was planning to sell one of
Kale's artifacts to someone else help me get
my daughter back black market is the most goth
form of retail it's right there in the name yeah
is anyone here hello answer me damn it it's been
a long time since anyone spoke to Dr poison that
way oh and the bride which one of you is Dr cyber
she's the one I negotiated with that's for sure
she's keeping an eye out for us do you
have the item I want my money I need to
make sure it's viable first please show
me the money it's not going to negotiate
did you double crossed us kill her
[Music] yes freaking gauntlets man
so cool that case belongs to Veronica kale
poison I'd get out of there if I were you
here's the agents takes the Hero Let's Go
Kill Bill time for a rematch Wonder win
wow no giganta bigger and better
[__] I haven't started saying that
well done James Cameron always thinking
ahead setting always thinking
outside the box real 3D move
nice I secured the artifact
and I managed not to pay for it
now that I will not allow yeah
this is an interesting choice for a villain I
never thought I'd see Wonder Woman fight like
a giant lady yeah bigger batter [__]
that's right how does her saying go the
bigger they are the more they fall down yes
that's it yes that's it exactly move Steve
thank you
wonderwood I think we can all agree
you've made some poor Life Choices
yep I love like the using the settings to
fight that the animated movies do well um
oh dude
story right there yeah she's she's dead
touch me Vanessa Vanessa you'll find a
vat of chemicals to jump into you didn't
shoot Julia she didn't get hit by a Ricochet
either the angles were all wrong I checked a
dozen times I should have been able to
save her who shot her Vanessa shot her
disgusting I had to test cheap sentiment
oh yep all the way all the way for all time always
and that's how Daphne broke bad yep she became
the villain under the moon oh which would have
gotten away with a deer from these meddling up
she don't know who she is I'm curious
cool with the silhouetting too
crack
we have a delivery for the doctors as for
your payment I wouldn't worry about it oh
she's smuggling medical equipment Tech
and artifacts she's young thinks she's
alone we need to show her that's
not true can you get us transport
something discreet I know just the
thing sure you do what do we got oh
does it go invisible is it discreet can we fly
it through fireworks that's all I ask [Music] yes
oh I love flying you never flew with me
yeah well you were flying with Superman
and there is a crowd I mean I'm
not flying with Superman now oh
get him Jim I'm gonna show her where the
hair intertwines is all right let's rock and
roll are you worried yeah that's why I'm not
dead yet that's good that's such a good line
I always love that moves bonking two
people together yeah it's so efficient
can it's just gonna be the hard
way I look pretty easy to me
yes yeah see hard way sorry Steve
yeah yeah whoa
gee I drove Vibes I can handle whoever's storming
the gates I knew you were a fighter that night in
the warehouse show me how much more you've
become since then oh boy she's not ready
all the upgrades no but she is Expendable wow guys
Vanessa Vanessa's dead oh damn cruel it's Silver
Swan now Silvers I do not know this character
but I'm excited to learn yeah Sam [Music]
he's getting Archangel they are not your
friends of course they are they help me kill you
oh Steven
Vanessa's not in her right mind the mutilation
she's endured is proof enough of that we need
someone whose only concern is helping
her a therapist super therapist yes
security facility
cyborg speak of the devil
how about two out of three did you not give
a mouse checks that seems dangerous yeah
like cable whoa she's being turned into it
from the inside out and it's still going on
the worst part is I can't find any off switch
or a reverse mechanism in theory I could heal
her but she doesn't have the time and I don't have
the tech the mascara does the purple healing Ray
science if it's so easy why'd you need to come
here you out of free miles on your rewards card
I don't know where that mascara is I don't know
what a rewards card is as soon as anyone leaves
the island they forget its location but you're
going to find it again for Vanessa I have to oh
if you promise to bring me back something nice
I know exactly where you can start somehow
didn't expect the purple healing raid callback
yeah didn't think of all the things that would
be the thing yeah the main plot device this was
Julia's office she always talked about the mascara
finding it was her personal Pet Project thank you
Veronica kale there are notes in here about Medusa
cells being used in treatment I didn't even
know she was real you didn't think I was real
the first time we met uh I was concussed he also
couldn't read Perseus I mean not doing so great
I knew about the island before she met kale
so her notes won't be on the top of the piles
they'd be on the bottom or in the middle or
between the middle and the bottom we need a
super filer yeah oh yes this case by itself here
the Temple of pacify Fame goddess of pacifiers
she's an oracular goddess associated with mazes
she helps people see the future if her Shrine
is still intact it could point the weight
killer that's a cool word what the hell are
we waiting for oracular I like that word a lot
oracular like an oracle of to see that's cool
how do you even get to a place
like this on foot not quickly
oh there she is you may have saved
your friends but you're my real Target
whoa cool you've improved but you haven't
beaten me yet well good but I'm better
and you won't now poison and cyber have
formed irregular villains Incorporated to
take you down including me oh a giant cheetah yes
because I'll like jackly corporate cheetah
[Music]
it's like flash speed Steve
does any of this bother you
uh you mean the dirt no that's just a you thing
oh we got a send Tower yes stop photos
gave birth to the Minotaur the Beast of
the maze oh sorry Minotaur I can't
believe my eyes sent out the horse
guy a Minotaur a centaurs centaur's a
horse guy I said Centaur I meant Mana
Tower it's all good apologies comments
this is how we learn that's how we learn
yes hey Willie I found a
shortcut through your hedge maze
ow feeling a little slow Yes
actually I am whoa It's honest
what are you doing changing the battlefield
[Laughter] that's great
lasso stay
can't leave me like this
you know deep down what's right yeah how
does this Shrine thing work do you hit star
for customer service or you ask politely
Choose Wisely show me the way home [Music]
Diana oh boy
whoa
oh snap you I pledge my life
to you Diana of the mascara
cool and I will shelter and protect you for all of
my days Ferdinand yeah the ball an excellent Name
great my man we found this on some of the
molecules from poisoning wow my text found
our Micro stamp as soon as We examined Vanessa's
blood work whose voice is that I can't tell but
it's familiar yeah maybe she deserves to stay
the way she is what Vanessa did she did from
pain she thinks Julia died disappointed
in her do you know how much that can hurt
my mother could freeze ice with a look children
drinks that way ah she might be a metahuman good
line you've talked me back to the side of the
angels I feel good Wonder Woman is like she
makes people good around her through reason so
good it's good writing the mediterranean's so
overfished certain species have been reduced to
Tiny Pockets that mascara could be the place where
all those components meet okay princess which of
these looks familiar I love too that she's calling
her princess is just an actual title yeah it's
not condescending it's not like yeah yeah it works
seek and ye shall find there's a seamount
an underwater Island how much you want to
bet it's a little bit taller in real
life now that you've found the mascara
Dr poison and I have too how did you access our
private server uh uh I've heard about the tech
the Amazons have it's hours for the taking
killing all of you is just good business oh
cyber turned on the contamination protocols
the computer thinks a virus is loose and it's
been ordered to sanitize with fire his
entire floor is about to be incinerated
uh uh whoa swan song what a cool story this is
great I like everybody's motivation I like the
way that like the story is developing itself
yeah personal why does it always get worse
don't ask that because we're going
into the third act safe Trevor
you're trying to steal my power just
like you stole my mother oh your voice
is changing with the yeah this isn't you I
want this do you it won't bring Julia back
it won't make her say she was proud
of you guns so freaking primitive
a bomb on the other hand
Swan get out of there while she's
while she's hey wait I can't fly
oh Jesus oh geez
you just had to wait for the
dramatic entrance didn't you
I thought you liked a little drama yeah the
poison and cyber may have declared war on
the mascara but if there's one thing Amazons
know it's how to fight a war and fast shipping
I've always had to be ironic to order anything
Wonder Woman from Amazon yeah does it come with
special accoutrements won't be staying for
dinner Ferdinand yes where'd you get that
shirt that is a very nice shirt on him this looks
great Ferdinand he did good work absolutely yeah
nice it's going OG suit up
visor [Music]
let's go team
next stop themiskira and hopefully
an Amazon who likes them thick yeah
yeah get it uh it's funny hook it up Diana
whatever happens there's a good chance she's
not coming back with us unless she had a little
motivation oh you're the best Wing man wing lady
you know that's exactly the effect I like to
have on women oh you're gonna save your own
Hometown you play your cards right they'll make
you Queen give you the key to the city at least
invitation back I stole this armor I betrayed my
own mother after you left we fought I turned my
sword on my own mother oh boy and Amazon does
what is right no matter the cost you mean the
world to me die I I just wish he wouldn't be so
hard on yourself Oh you mean the world to me too
oh it's here I know it
oh oh no
man's world has come to the mascara
make sure they do not find it wanting
let's go
I do so love mass destruction let's
hope she does too God who's in there
[Music]
Sonic attacks like that always seem
especially harsh yeah sound hurts like
I'd be doubly painful concussive and yeah
I'm just rattling all yourselves I'd love
to get a Venom movie to like make you feel
like that like a sound design yeah like the
sound of metal but for like Venom oh like out of
Venom the sound of venom surrender surrender oh
no
oh boy once that attack is ours I'm going
to build an army of you strong enough
Mortals talk too much I love the
snakes talking with her so cool
No One controls my feet awesome my apologies
Medusa I can make you stronger I did not come
here to rob the Amazons oh look at me wretch
look at me Hector I came to destroy them don't
stop the money Medusa whoa she's staying dead
it's also wondering how she could gaze upon
them without just turning them immediately
[Music] I should still take it anywhere
this is a nightmare
it's not gonna go great we'll just stand there
that giant statue was already a statue
I like that I don't know how one room is
gonna take her out yeah like it's fun yeah
Gatling arrows
back
Vanessa stop you can still be healed
oh this is an eye for an eye Diana
you hurt me and now I hurt you it's not the way
no matter what you've done I'm still with you
I Won't Let You Go
that always gets me want to run so great no
oh no no
I got this but you don't know how to oh
I got this I had a candy MVP Percy has killed
Medusa I'm now I've been reading could a mere
replicant do this we do not have to
be your enemies we have always been
Diana I promise to turn her to Stone
before I take off her limbs well
I will not allow yeah let's go
cool
thank you [Music]
foreign
[Music]
Steve what just a gun wow
dude Steve no don't look no
oh I must remember that
now you got a better yeah
[Music]
ow ow big ass snake a very
special Venom it's through
almost anything it's got that adrenaline momentum
cool yes
wolf oh wow this girl Vanessa's just been handed
whoa [Applause] gotta take your head off oh no
yes wow that's how you pull someone's hair
but they're also snakes yeah look at me girl
listen to me Vanessa I will not let her harm you
no I know you think that that you're not enough
for those who loved you I felt that fear too but
I knew my purpose in this life and if it is at
all in my power you will survive long enough to
learn yours yes oh she can't see you through me
look at me first
oh I refuse
you can't poison me with my own
Venom oh blindfold with a snake
not what I was oh oh you applied yourself oh
whoa damn that was metal as hell that's hard yeah
oh
yeah wow
the princess cannot survive this
she will die if she can take the
monster with her like a true
Amazon oh earning that respect
yes [Music]
you wanted me to choose a path for myself
Diana I choose to stand by you oh jeez
[Music] like ax kick keep a hand on me I'll
get you to her you do the rest together
[Music]
well done
oh like wait a second I was
like how's this myth cup yeah
oh
I'm sorry I couldn't be the daughter you wanted
oh there you go that's a good
pause you were a true Amazon today
I know the title they gave you
in man's world you have earned
their name you truly are a Wonder
Woman why did you say that please
yeah but I came here with the
mission will you help us oh
purest heart it's so well written because
one of them is just good like just this
the good yeah oh purple he like rice for
everyone everybody gets it use a little
Mirror action I'm glad they made it to
Elysium [Music] congratulations angel
get it respect to Diana the champion of famous
Kira you earned it known to all as Wonder Woman
cool [Applause] what a great retcon to the weird
New 52 choice they did the beginning this late
in the game they're like let's fix one yeah
right before the end we got one more thing to
do make sure we get it right it is my honor to
Proclaim let the games commence yeah yeah cool
nicely done I really dug that one yeah I did
too it was lovely yeah I mean they they really
reconfigured who their Wonder Woman was
they really made it work for both their
continuity that established kind of like with
Superman had like they told an iconic story
but we had to get there with the character
first yeah I didn't know this story I knew
pieces of it like this didn't feel like one
storyline that I I know but like they did a
really good job making that work yeah totally
like this had a really nice gradual build that
yeah it started really grounded and it started
you know just like kind of like an actual movie
not to say that these haven't all felt like
that and not to say that it's bad when you
start out you know like you know already you
know hitting the ground running but I I loved
just her journey to going back in time a
little bit journeying to man's world oh
oh she is villains I thought there was something
wrong with her why Dr kale Julia never stopped
raving about you marvelous Amazons whose
technology I couldn't even dream of I could
take it but the only person that could find
it oh boy you killed Julia dang I couldn't let
her figure out I was bankrolling poison in cyber
damn whoa they successfully made me forget about
the Ricochet yeah you're your attack failed the
mascara is whole and exactly where I left it I'm
looking forward to visiting ugh you asked me to
bring you back something from home oh beheadings
my mother and I are reconciled thanks to
you which means I am now officially the
champion of the mascara if you seek to harm
it or my friends you should have a weapon
friggin boss you are not worthy I'm intimidated
amazing I'm Coming For You Wonder Woman do
Wonder Woman I am coming for you amazing oh that
was perfect so they removed this from the desk
so yeah if in time okay Rosario Dawson stayed
okay uh uh let's see who do we got here constant
Zimmer was Veronica kale that's what I couldn't
place okay certainly damn and we got some uh
some Creator credits for the characters yes as it
should be I've really enjoyed that one man yeah
and and yeah like I was saying like I really liked
going back in time a few years seeing how she gets
to man's world and then watching this sort of
gradual build of like okay Fish Out of Water
she's being taken in she's being given housing and
whatnot and yeah making this relationship with uh
uh uh Vanessa and her mom and all that stuff
and then slowly growing into a big superhero
Stakes kind of story from there and it was always
personal to some extent yeah you know like it was
always yeah a personal story that then begs those
kinds of choices those kinds of moral quandaries
of like yeah how do I stay true but also stay
on the righteous path you know and then and The
Duality between uh like betraying your family
and your family betraying you and like you know
being a good daughter and you feeling like you
know your your parents doesn't love you like
the the parallels between her and Vanessa really
interesting because like they both were loved by
their family in ways that didn't benefit them but
deep down the love was there and that was really
interesting to have like abusive love because
they expect too much from you in both directions
and how like when you raise someone that can
turn you like if you don't love your kid right
if you don't give enough compassion if you don't
give enough encouragement if you only you know
try and discipline your way to yeah to to yeah
too much expectation for both of them yeah and
even though it's not like a huge thing you do
get the sense that like um what was her name
Julia like you know she is so you know uh wait
is there another scene do we got another scene
no okay yeah with Julia it's like you know she's
kind of fawning over Diana and she's you know
accommodating her in all these various ways and
and it almost seems like in in a roundabout way
she's getting a taste of that motherly approval
that she was deprived of which that makes it all
the worst for Vanessa to have to watch that yeah
Vanessa in the beginning like genuinely caring
and just being a good kid and like seeing that
descent I really liked how maybe more than most
of them I really felt every single person's Arc
yeah like I really bought even the villain uh the
corporate villain like I I didn't even think I I
love how good this was that I didn't remember to
think about the Ricochet but also that I felt
something I was off about her but it wasn't
so heavy-handed yeah and then also everyone's
motivation felt real and I love that Steve Trevor
wasn't just relegated to like you know sidekick
he still felt like he had his own Journey but it
was a very female story which is something I
also think the Patty Jenkins first movie did
well was Chris Pine was incredible but it never
was no one got shortchanged by the importance of
like a female-led story yeah absolutely just so
happy like you know it just kind of Hit Me part
way through of like oh this is like pretty much
all of the prominent characters are are female
and then you have Steve and Steve isn't like a
joke you know like he's perfectly capable and
he's fine backing up Diana he loves Diana like
I like their relationship I really like how the
balance is really Charming yeah absolutely and
and it's doing all these things without calling
attention to the fact that it's doing all these
things and it feels I don't know just yeah the
way they laid it out it felt really natural and
even the way that Veronica Falls in with uh with
Dr cyber and Dr poison and having it be you know
like kind of rogue's gallery of female villains
again in a natural way yeah and Wonder Woman
villains certainly but yeah just I don't know it
became female Centric in a way that I thought was
like really lovely and gradual and an exemplary
of of you know some of the great characters
that they've built on this side of the DC
Spectrum in general and when it's like
all dudes now and notices because that's
the standard so it's nice that when it's all
women and it doesn't feel like it's telling
you it's all women it's just a story with
women like that's what I always enjoy about
like Wonder Woman is she's just so good and when
you write her correctly like this you don't like
you don't want anything but goodness for everyone
in their life like you don't want it like everyone
that she was fighting she wanted good for everyone
that was betraying her she just wanted to end well
and like that's the power of Wonder Woman is like
she's so good I loved that truly yeah it seems
like truly somebody wants to leave everything a
little bit better than she found it and who feels
an immense amount of responsibility for anything
when she becomes involved with it right Superman
like this write Wonder Woman like this that's why
they're like beautiful opposites to Bruce as Bruce
is so broken and they're so whole and like they
need each other to understand the humanity because
it's complex yeah I I thought this was uh one of
my this is probably my top third like this was
definitely exemplary uh I loved the villain love
that it balanced like it had like great cheetah
moment I love the balance so many villains I love
that everyone's Arc felt Justified I loved the
art style and how it suited the Amazons I love the
lore I mean this was really great yeah absolutely
and the flourishes of Greek mythology and stuff
like that I love that you go into the Labyrinth
and you have the minute tour it's adapted for this
context uh yeah Ferdinand I thought that was great
and uh and and two I don't know something about
the giant effect you got giganta and then you
have a giant Medusa was like I don't know like
you know we've seen giant characters and giant
villains and stuff before but there was something
striking about that here to me and I agree yeah
maybe it's just because it does build so gradually
and it does exist on a lot of human scales too but
yeah watching her fight these Giants I was like
yeah this this does seem like it would be really
hard and also like it is like a very Fantastical
superheroes type of situation and it added scope
but it also added story elements of Greek it added
that that like sense of that world I also really
like there's only one thing that I would tweak and
that feels good that it's only one thing I would
have loved a line from Medusa like you know you're
the the champion of the mascara you've earned my
fight or something that like why she didn't
just Stone her right away yeah and then like
her getting mad and being like bro and going to do
it and then her blinding yourself like something
to like Allah allow for that fight to happen that
long because everyone else got turned to stone I'm
like why wouldn't she just do that to her she's
clearly looking at her face yeah she's clearly the
biggest threat on the field something to just like
an honor or a respect you know like I'm gonna kill
you last or but like that was my biggest flaw and
that's great in this type of Storytelling when my
biggest flaws like I'll line a dialogue yeah yeah
absolutely like this had this this of all of them
feels they've they're all obviously they're
all films but like this this felt more like
akin to the PACE and tone of something live action
I would have loved this as a sequel sure to the
first one sure the Patty Jenkins first one like
a betrayal of Robin Wright and she's gotta like
earn it back and like go back to the mascara like
this was so well put together yeah yeah yeah and
it's like I love that this is absolutely you know
taking advantage of the animated you know medium
sure uh but do so yeah absolutely and and you know
the Giants and all that stuff but uh and and like
I love the way they realize that mascara and all
that but yeah like something this this one felt
unique amid all these dcamu movies because of the
way it moved and because of how the tone was and
because of again just that sort of really kind
of poised attention to character it didn't seem
like it was in a rush to get to anything I like
that yeah you're right and like there's plenty
of action but it never feels like that's the main
priority and it just feels so well-rounded and and
yeah and that you know kind of essence of goodness
emanates off of it without sacrificing some of the
harsh moments and things like that like this
was this was like really nicely proportioned I
thought this was like yeah this was very graceful
top tier in a way I wasn't expecting and yeah I
I quite quite enjoyed it uh so we've only got
a couple at the DC in this universe left this
was 2019 it is currently 2023 as we're recording
this uh I think we've got two you said I think
this might be the second to last one there's only
one might be apocalypse words I'll have to double
check so we've got either one or two left um
don't know if we're gonna do that next or if
we're gonna steer away into another one but
I do think we're gonna wrap up this universe
we're gonna keep going after but uh do like a
ranking video and it's been really interesting
to like feel the different Vibes and I'm really
curious how this one went over because I know
like I didn't love the original take of Wonder
Woman the new 52 when they introduced her in
this post Flashpoint Universe was not for me
but they fixed well quippy but also like the
earnestness wasn't Earnest it was like arrogant um
looking down as a god remember she would like show
at me like these humans I was like it's Wonder
Woman she loves humans like it felt so wrong it
felt so much Detachment yeah she was just like a
warrior fights and I was like who is this [Music]
it was literally someone that left everything
you've loved behind to protect the people you're
judging arrogantly like who are you yeah and I get
there's different tags there's different different
ages in 52 whatever but like it was not Wonder
Woman sure like there are some things that are
the core of a character that like the archetype
is vital to make the character who the character
is and for me it's Batman doesn't shoot people and
for me it's Larkin loves helping people and for me
it's Wonder Woman Loves humanity and so it was so
weird when some of these were like we're gonna do
the opposite yeah so I I just really made me happy
no totally totally totally because yeah it still
gets all the cool stuff that you want and there's
even some humor involving Diana yeah but yeah it
really feels like spiritually on point and I mean
you would know certainly with greater context than
an eye but yeah that that it never really even
those earlier installments I was kind of like
oh used to this take on Wonder Woman and if
I'm saying that then yeah that seems off yeah
it must be a little bit uh outside the box and
I'm glad Rosario got to come back and like do
the Justice thing she she's always been great it
was good to see her playing the Wonder Woman that
I think of as Wonder Woman yeah in this context
yeah absolutely oh really Doug this uh definitely
one of my top tier ones I uh I'm really excited
to see how it ends 2019 you know we're catching
up to modern day I'm also curious like when this
universe ends how things take off from it like
what is everything just separate it's all you
know I love not knowing this I also love that I
didn't know that villain I didn't know um Silver
Silver Swan Silver Swan didn't know silver swine
so this was fun for me as a comic fan to like
enjoy something completely removed except for
my level Wonder one so yeah this was delightful
delightful dope all right well that is gonna do it
for this episode of man that was cool uh watching
the DC animated movies but rather enjoying them
we've got one left in this continuity and then
uh we're gonna keep journeying through so let
us know in the comments which you want us to watch
next very excited to do a koi's comic corner with
John I haven't done that since the first one
Wolverine since Wolverine way back in the days
we're gonna be ranking them together absolutely
uh probably gonna do one where it's just the the
that universe and then when we're done one where
it's all 50 whatever of them which is gonna be
insane in 2029 when we get to it when we dude it's
gonna be a four hour video that's right but we're
not I'm not editing it uh but yeah so uh next up
is either gonna be the end of this continuity or
something else entirely we'll find out but leave
a comment below remember liking this is how we
know you in fact liked this sharing this is how
we get to keep making them because that shows
that you guys are in fact liking them before
we go let's do a patron of the day shout out
we're gonna give it up to David Gandy because
that name sure is Handy and man oh Mandy do I
like a nice name that rhymes with candy uh I
really enjoy your name David Gandy I hope it
has served you well I hope you've given it honor
as Diana has given her the mascara honor I love
that Diana Prince is a princess but since her
last name is Prince it allows a certain tone
of regality it also allows the name to both
be uh neutral sexually but like as in like
sex male or female but I've also always liked
that like Diana Prince is a strong masculine
name for a very strong feminine woman I think
it's a really interesting uh dichotomy of how
we like label things like we we are working on
changing actress to just actor because it's one
who acts not necessarily like stewardess and I've
always thought Diana Prince for a character from
the 60s was a really like Progressive name and
concept so I wanted to give some love to another
very cool name which is David Gandy uh and uh we
appreciate you being a patron we appreciate you
as ever being a super sexy reject and uh thank
you absolutely and you know what you know what
yeah you know what that rhymes with what do you
got add a candy add a candy David Gandy doing the
DC continuity work good call excellent rap out
we will see you soon for the next one foreign